[Music]
the memes for this stop it no don't stop
it I I cannot with the memes for this
are you on Twitter just laughing your
butt off at these like I am I am I don't
know if this has ever happened to me
people are so funny and so clever and I
think it's only just begun I think so
yeah I love seeing them
[Music]
heading into your 16th studio album
tension after the critical and
Commercial Success of something like
disco do you feel a bit of pressure to
match that
it should but
did it I was about to say no but then I
just dialed back to the sleepless nights
there was just my pressure I didn't feel
outside pressure I wanted to be back in
the world and I wanted to be able to
deliver
attention it doesn't sound right is
there a certain Freedom you're feeling
at this point because when I listen to
the new single in my mind I am hearing
Freedom I'm hearing liberation
[Music]
foreign
yeah I do it's a different state of mind
for me it was great that there was
really no Direction it was it was
servicing the songs actually so they
more or less told me in the end
so which Kylie are we having right now
what is the tension Erica I don't know
yet I don't know
it's too early for me to say well I'm
just gonna say I'm gonna call it the red
hot Kylie Jenner